so my my paper is entitled dispute
settlement and the South China Sea from
joint phone apps to join proceedings and
this paper tries to engage with the the
framework of this framework of thought
that we're given with regard to the
application of own clothes and dispute
settlement in particular but what I'm
trying to do here is to go beyond I'm
close beyond the dispute settlement
proceedings that we've seen so far and
to see how we can really go from these
bilaterals to a more multi-party
approach and first I'll start with
assessing the current situation which
brought me to bring up these points
today and also as a way to define the
terms more precisely what i use the word
dispute settlement this is in a broad
sense so obviously i'm talking about
arbitrations under annex 7 but i'm also
talking about the opportunities for
participation at the ICJ at it Lohse
even if those are not as relevant and
the South China Sea as of now and first
looking at the current situation I
identified three important points first
was the failure of the ASEAN framework
several the speakers have talked to
extinct extensive links about this about
how the Declaration of conduct was not
followed by an effective code of conduct
and how the different negotiation rounds
did not ultimately result in any
meaningful progress on the resolving
these disputes and the South China Sea
second is the military buildup which
many speakers have described as well as
the freedom of navigation operate
that have been conducted by the US in
particular but not only and I will touch
upon these operations further and then
from a dispute settlement point of view
one of the only significant developments
was the PC arbitration between
Philippines and China the case number 2
2013 19 so I I've already touched upon
the failure of the as an framework here
are some of the important milestones and
an important point to keep in mind is as
some of the speakers noted was that
China has now an agreement with Brunei
Cambodia and Laos to only negotiate
these disputes and a bilateral framework
which obviously circumvents part of the
effort to make this a multi-party a
multi-party approach going back to the
phone ops some of the speaker's touched
upon this it's codified and enclose 87 1
a and it's the simplest way to define it
is that the ships flying the flag of a
sovereign state shall not suffer
interference from other states and this
was stated in the US oceans policy in
1983 and it's been systematically
reasserted if you've listened to
Secretary of Defense Ashton Carter
recently he makes these types of
statements quite often and some some of
the interesting developments recently
were signs that Australia Japan and the
Philippines have either conducted or
expressed their interest in conducting
phone ups in the South China Sea and we
know that for some of them they already
have started conducting the phone apps
especially for Australia and the
Philippines has just agreed on
conducting such operations with the US
Navy which shows that we're really
expanding beyond the scope of
these bilaterals we're moving to a point
where we're trying to include all the
different parties inside in order to
perhaps have a more successful outcome
in these proceedings and just to show
you what the US Department of Defense
two weeks ago just published its fiscal
year 2015 report on these phone ups and
they they list them in a in a alpha
build alphabetical order and this is for
China you can see what the types of
excessive maritime claims that are being
contested and I compared this with the
2014 iteration and what's been added
since then is the prior permission
required for innocent passage of foreign
military ships through the territorial
sea but other than that in 2014 the US
had the same concerns I've also
highlighted the other some of the other
South China Sea claimants what their
excessive claims are because one of the
main tenets of the US phone ops is that
it does not target a specific country
this is really about upholding freedom
of navigation so we see that Malaysia
Philippines of Vietnam as well and so
moving on now the PCA arbitration is I
said is the only significant dispute
settlement development that we've seen
and I won't go into all the details that
some of the speakers have gone into this
is the arbitral panel the five
arbitrators very distinguished and so
looking at this current situation I
asked myself several questions and the
first one was how can these South China
Sea claimants and stakeholders utilize
the dispute settlement mechanism under
and close and under other frameworks
to their fullest potential and second
how can they translate increasing levels
of cooperation into legal actions and
finally how can these claimants overcome
non-participation forceful bilateralism
and bring parties into compliance China
in particular in my outline is the
following I'll first look at the
procedural opportunities in South China
Sea dispute settlement mechanisms not an
unclothed but not only and then i'll
show how this is really about bringing
what i would call strategic litigation
in the South China Sea so first the
available for under own clothes mrs.
Hong mentioned these very well so i
won't go into details this is the
article 287 the ICJ at lowes an annex
seven arbitration annex seven
arbitration being the default solution
and here as Miss Hong rightly pointed
out none of the South China Sea
claimants have elected one of these
mechanisms which makes annex Evan the
default solution however we should not
necessarily neglect the other fora such
as the ICJ and it lowes first because
China might might in the future except
the jurisdiction of one of these of one
of these fora and second other South
China Sea claimants are not precluded
from using these fora for resolving the
disputes between themselves these are
some of the relevant articles them going
to go over and moving to my first part
on the potential for third-party
participation enjoying proceedings and
here I need to define some of the third
terms because when you're talking about
international law international
pute settlement a lot of these terms
will come up and they don't necessarily
mean the same thing in the same context
so what I'm talking about joint
proceedings this is Anna broad sense
which means that I encompass situations
where parties are either joining a
dispute as a party to the dispute or
intervening maybe it's a third party
submitting some evidence in writing some
submitting some memoranda it's the same
when we're talking about third party or
third person and some instances a third
party might be considered especially if
you have a capital P usually it means
that this is a party to the treaty
however and some other treaties
especially an investor say arbitration
we have situations where the third party
will be a party which is not a party to
the treaty so a private person you also
come across the terms interested party
non disputing party amicus curiae is an
important word in these proceedings it
means friend of the court and Latin and
this is a usually this is a letter or a
submission to the court as a friend of
the court to help the court in order to
adjudicate some of the claims we've also
seen in the context of the South China
Sea the note value which are originally
diplomatic notes but what happened which
have become relevant as well in dispute
settlement because they might be taken
into account by tribunals and also
unilateral statements of Vietnam made
one of these statements in 2014 through
its prime minister and it's the PCA
panel actually incorporated this
statement into their written written
evidence that they were considering so
going back to the ICJ these are two of
the relevant articles that deal with the
participation by interested parties so
this is for interested state parties
um and cure some of the cases in which
the ICJ authorized this participation
but it never did so an a really i would
say in a comprehensive manner it there
were always reservations and this is
often the case in dispute settlement
tribunals will rarely allow third
parties or even interested state parties
to really have full access to the
proceedings they will usually allow them
to intervene for specific points of law
or a fact so here are some of these
cases and as I said there is limited
success for either intervention from
state parties or third-party
intervention and here I should just go
back on one of the items that were was
mentioned by a previous speakers that I
CJ dispute settlement is based on the
consent of both parties so here in the
South China Sea as long as China refuses
the jurisdiction of the ICJ it has never
submitted itself to an IC j panel then
we won't be able to use it however other
some of the other South China Sea
claimants might have recourse to the ICJ
second it loose this is one of the
relevant articles that's in the in close
article 31 request to intervene and this
is just one of the cases I noted for you
actually have two parties the southern
bluefin tuna case two parties Australia
New Zealand bringing a claim against
Japan and here the two parties were
considered as having the same interest
and so they're in a way they're their
participation and this proceeding was as
if they were one party but it does show
how even in these proceedings you might
have a multiplication of different
parties and maybe one day and the South
China Sea we could hopefully see some of
the parties come together and if they
agree on some points maybe Cole has some
of their claims I also looked at em
Korea under atlas these are two examples
of attempts to submit amicus create buy
it by the Greenpeace the first one was
in case number 17 the responsibilities
and obligations of state sponsoring
persons and entities with respect to
activities in their international seabed
area and then the second one was for the
Arctic sunrise case which I'll go back
to later on because it's it's also an
interesting case in the South China Sea
context because Russia also refused to
participate in these proceedings but
just to go back to these amicus curious
submissions and the both cases it was
refused to allow the amicus curious
omission and it was in fact the the
first time in the context of it low
swear it really set this precedent
however it did publish the amicus create
on its website which shows that even if
a party is not granted access to the
proceedings it might still have an
impact and this is important in the
context of a South China Sea where we've
seen Vietnam in particular interested
and perhaps intervening or participating
then we have unclose and x7 which is
obviously the most relevant for us I
mentioned the Vietnamese submission but
there's also been a Taiwanese submission
which is here on the right and both of
these submissions well the Vietnamese
statement is in fact a statement it's
not really a proper amicus curiae
however as I said it was incorporated
into the pca's decision-making process
and as a general matter I should know
that amicus briefs are usually only
authorised when they meet several
criteria when they are when they deal
with the matter within the scope of the
dispute when the party submitting the
amicus curiae has a significant
when it can assist in resolving a
factual legal question and also
sometimes if it is independent from the
parties under this pew so I'm going to
move along so this was another
submission I'm going to move to creative
approaches beyond unclosed because this
is a very important I think a very
important field which hasn't really been
explored because as was mentioned by
some previous speakers we've seen
success and promoting compliance in
other areas such as international trade
at the WTO China has been a very willing
party has participated obviously and at
the end of the year there is a question
of whether China will qualify as a
market economy status which will have a
strong impact on probably the way it
sees the WTO after this but in any case
this is an example of successful example
in which a dispute settlement binding
dispute settlement proceeding is
accepted by China there's also a
question of bringing investor-state
disputes in the South China Sea we've
seen a rise and the use of state-owned
organizations n investor-state
arbitration that that's a very
contentious issue however there's been
significant scholarship on this
particular issue in showing that this is
really an increasing trend and in
particular I went to look at some of the
bi TS the bilateral investment trees
between some of the parties and so I
looked at the China Vietnam vit and here
in the Articles three and four we have
some of the standards of protection
there's the standard of full protection
and security so on the left or just some
of the standard protections you find in
most of these agreements full protection
and security national treatment most
favored nation no expropriation without
compensation so these all offer possible
avenues for South China Sea claimants
and the China has accepted to submit
itself to some exit arbitrations exit is
the body of the World Bank which
administers some of these disputes so
this is another avenue for parties
claimants or in private parties which
wish to have an impact here and within
the global context of law fair this is
an important thing to keep in mind I'll
just quickly go over the rationale of
these of maybe initiating these
proceedings or participating the US
phone up rationale as I said there are
several different tenants that are here
but the the real idea is to bring
strategic litigation and strategic
litigation is an American concept which
was developed usually we refer to it
when we think about the civil rights era
Brown versus Board of Education and it's
about bringing systemic change through
litigation and here I believe that we
can bring systemic change perhaps
through litigating through participation
by some of the other South China Sea
claimants and some of the perspectives
in light of this the arbitration case at
the PCA it is important to keep in mind
that China submitted a position paper
which is quite extensive a 90 paragraphs
and which deals with a lot of they try
to rebut a lot of the jurisdictional
arguments of the Philippines and so and
for me this is the functional equivalent
of a counter memorial and in effect
China did in a way join itself to the
proceeding through this submission but
other claimants may also send briefs to
to the annex seven panels such as
Vietnam did through its statement that
was incorporated and this was on a
februari 6 2015 and this shows
just to conclude the value of the
process it's the process itself that
really is the key here all the speakers
during these two days have shown that
dispute resolution alone is not going to
bring any change and we're probably not
gonna actually going to see any
enforceable awards and the future
however if all the South China Sea
claimants or at least a strong number of
them bring claims show their commitment
to the process this could actually
really bring some of the systemic change
that Alice talking about and this is not
only for some claimants in the South
China Sea it's also for third part party
organisations think about the fisheries
the oil and gas industry and this is
really about looking at this from a
creative point of view and showing that
we can really move from joint freedom of
navigation operations which kind of
exemplify military might but we can use
the same tactics here in the context of
this Butte settlement and this is the
Peace Palace into hey it's really nice I
recommend for everyone when it wants to
go there and it's where both the PCA and
the ICJ or seated there right across the
hall so thank you very much
you